The Avengers aren't the only ones making
a huge comeback this year Disney and
Marvel Studios have made the unexpected
decision to rehire James Gunn to finish
what he started with the guardians of
the galaxy series what happened in the
months since guns firing to make this
unlikely triumph possible to call guns
firing in July 2018 unexpected would be
a bit of an understatement
under guns Direction the guardians came
out of nowhere to become one of the most
successful series in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe pretty impressive for
a property that was all but unknown
before 2014 on top of the money the
movies brought in they also earned rave
reviews making talking trees and trash
pandas beloved household names for
families across the world you stupid
raccoon but his guns sudden firings
seemed to demonstrate all of that
success meant nothing in the face of
corporate mandate the third guardians
movie was originally set to begin
filming in fall 2018 but was shut down
indefinitely after the controversial
decision was made to fire gun for
provocative past tweets
a few days after Disney's decision was
made public the main cast of the
franchise rebuked the company with an
extraordinary open letter calling for
gun to be reinstated the remarkable show
of support left many hoping that the
situation could be turned around but
publicly the company was unswayed and it
soon looked like Disney would rather
scuttle vol.3 in its entirety than bring
gun back if many movies in the MCU feel
like they're designed by committee it's
mostly because well they are but guns
guardians of the galaxy movies are often
seen as being uniquely his using the
out-there humor of his satirical movies
with a more Disney approved
family-friendly vibe while we don't know
what went on internally in the wake of
guns firing fans and commentators
stressed over the idea of someone taking
over guns job as director how could a
replacement for gun effectively mimic
his style and even if it could wouldn't
it just feel kind of hollow rumors were
abundant to potential replacements for
the filmmaker including thor ragnarok
director Taika Waititi but according to
the deadline report that announced guns
reinstatement all of this chatter was
only rumor and Marvel Studios never
approached or considered any other
filmmaker to head up the delayed project
in the aftermath of James Gunn's firing
Drax the destroyer actor Dave Bautista
went to town on social media sharing to
anyone who would listen that he would
straight-up quit his job at Marvel
Studios declined to press forward with
guns vol.3 script the actor said in an
interview with shortlist where I'm at
right now is that if they don't use that
script then I'm going to ask them to
release me for my contract cut me out or
recast me I'd be doing James at his
service if I didn't well they're artista
had anything to do with it or not it was
soon reported that Marvel and Disney
would indeed be moving forward with guns
script it seems likely that the studio's
were in a tight bind regarding the
screenplay Guardians volume 2 clearly
laid the groundwork for future
storylines in the Marvel cosmic such as
the introduction of Adam warlock
presumably with the expectation that
guns volume 3 script would follow up on
them after that script was written and
incorporated into the MCU future it may
have been too difficult to get rid of
guns screenplay without compromising the
series's house of cards meta plot Plus
unless they completely threw out his
script and changed everything it may
have been impossible to rewrite guns
draft without having to credit him
anyway for laying the groundwork
according to the deadline report that
broke the story guns rehiring is not a
new development at least internally the
decision was apparently made months ago
in the aftermath of his firing gun kept
silent even as the reaction from fans
got louder and louder the writer
director received an enormous amount of
public support with one change.org
petition calling for his rehiring
getting hundreds of thousands of
signatures but despite the support Gunn
publicly accepted Disney's decision
which turned out to be the right move
apparently guns calm reaction to the
controversy helped convince Walt Disney
Studios chairman Alan horn that the
company had made the wrong call now it
looks like Gunn's refusal to burn
bridges has brought him the best of all
possible worlds a relationship with DC
and Marvel Studios and huge projects in
the works for both
in October just three months after being
shown the door by Disney gun
surprisingly loaded up his next project
with rival studios Warner Brothers and
DC being tapped both write and direct a
follow-up to DC's Suicide Squad people's
minds were blown so hard you think
Harley Quinn went to town on them with a
baseball bat before long many moviegoers
were already getting comfortable with
the new status quo assuming guardians of
the galaxy was done for and getting
weirdly excited about a Suicide Squad -
we're gonna start having some real fun
why don't we have some fun but it turns
out whatever deal Gunn's signed with
Warner Brothers wasn't an exclusive one
leaving him free to resume work on
volume 3 when he's wrapped up with the
Suicide Squad sequel one factor that may
have made it easy to bring gun back is
just how good for business the filmmaker
has been for Disney together the first
two movies in the guardians of the
galaxy series earned a combined total of
over 1.6 billion dollars and that's just
the movie money not the cash raked in by
toys
theme park rides and other properties
associated with the brand in the short
term guns history of tasteless jokes may
have felt damaging enough to Disney to
justify the backlash that would come
from firing him somewhere along the way
that seems to have changed and now
Disney and Marvel Studios are set to
deliver not just the highly anticipated
sequel but one many had resigned to
thinking was never going to happen the
way it was originally intended
apparently not even the mouse house can
say no to another easy billion James
Gunn's unique aptitude for working with
Marvel hasn't gone unnoticed over the
years with the once Fringe filmmaker
being drawn closer into the company's
brain trust at times it seemed possible
that he could one day take the whole
thing over should producer Kevin Feige
step down Feige himself has some guns
phrases in the past telling The
Hollywood Reporter that gun could quote
easily oversee additional stories in the
MCU beyond vol 3 now we might really get
to see all of that unfold after the news
broke that gun had been rehired for
volume 3 the writer director shared a
statement on his Twitter page writing I
am tremendously grateful to every person
out there who has supported me over the
past few months I deeply appreciate
Disney's decision and I am excited to
continue
in films that investigate the ties of
love that find us all check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]